vous donnez mère vu le caractère
inflammable de cette réforme est ce que
vous nous garantissez ce matin que le
gouvernement ne passera pas en force
n'utilisera pas le 49-3 pour faire
passer cette réforme ne peut pas le
donner cette garantie je ne souhaite pas
ça c'est certain et si le gouvernement
faisait passer deux forces la réforme
des retraites avec le 49-3 mais au fait
c'est quoi cet article de la
constitution
certains l'appellent l'arme nucléaire
législatives l'article 49 3 il consiste
à faire passer un projet de loi sans le
vote des parlementaires
savez vous qu'il a été utilisé 87 fois
depuis sa création en 1958 une seule
personne peut l'activer le premier
ministre et une grande majorité des
locataires de matignon l'ont fait sous
la vème république il engage alors la
responsabilité du gouvernement
[Applaudissements]
d'engager la responsabilité du
gouvernement engage donc la
responsabilité du gouvernement le 49 3
permet d'accélérer un débat jugé trop
long ou de contrer un blocage de
l'opposition mais l'assemblée nationale
peut l'annuler avec la motion de censure
elle doit être déposé dans les 24 heures
suivant le recours aux 49 3 exemple en
1989 le gouvernement rocard fait passer
de force le projet de loi sur la
sécurité sociale l'opposition réplique
les ministres ne prennent même pas la
peine d'expliquer ce qu'il propose on
parle dans les voiles a immédiatement
engageant 49 3 c'est à dire demandant la
confiance c'est à dire le tout au rien
sans qu'il y ait débat non ça ne peut
plus durer
motion de censure rejetée pourquoi car
elle n'a pas été approuvé par la
majorité des députés résultat le projet
de loi est validé michel rocard conforté
autre exemple en 2006 dominique de
villepin alors premier ministre mais le
projet de loi sur le cpe le contrat
première embauche notre pays
s'impatiente
il attend des réponses
la droite dégaine le 49-3 l'opposition
riposte avec une motion de censure nous
n'avons aucune crainte et cette censure
que vous ne penserez peut-être pas sur
les grands de cette majorité ce sont les
français qui le feront à votre place en
2007 là aussi motion de censure rejetée
car le ps n'a pas de majorité
parlementaire en revanche la loi n'a
jamais été appliquée en raison de la
fronde étudiante les législatives auront
un impact sur l'utilisation ou non du
49-3 pour la réforme des retraites si le
gouvernement veut éviter la motion de
censure il lui faut obtenir la majorité
parlementaire lors des élections
[Musique]